okay I'm about to get all Opera House on
you okay so these are we gonna do have a
look at this for me remember I told you
this is the familiar X Y axis you're
used to but that's that's laying flat
right we're used to seeing up on the
board but I've laid it down on the
ground okay and now going upwards we
have this vertical dimension okay
because I have a board you don't I right
but here's the weird part just have a
look at what's on the Cartesian plane
tell me what do you think the equation
of that thing is I think it's x squared
plus y squared equals 16 yeah that's
what it is okay that's a circle the
reason why it doesn't look exactly
circulars because we're looking at it
from an angle okay but the volume we're
going to make from this is not a solid
of revolution okay what I'm drawing up
from here and architecture bus will love
this is um these these cross-sections
are all triangular in fact they're not
just triangular for the sake of
simplicity we're going to make them all
equilateral triangles okay equilateral
dreamers now believe it or not that is
all the information you need to work out
this volume okay I will leave this all
on the board so you can see the way that
we did it before okay again I will
repeat you've got this circle that's
your base okay but then the actual
volume you're creating it's actually got
straight edges up there okay those are
all triangles they're they're not
they're not semi circles up here as if
you had a solid of revolution okay I
want you to see if you can work out this
is see if you can work out the volume of
this thing think about the way we've
built it before okay think about if
you're gonna need to have extra diagrams
to help you I'll let you have a stab at
it first before I show you the way I'll
do it okay good luck let's begin I need
to work on volume right
volume equals now look carefully you can
either take your slices or your shelves
we can take this example if you like and
let's start to construct this guy okay I
start with a limit and then you have to
choose what's that about
what's that limit about well I think
would be what does a signify you must
must must get this and not write down
calculus garbage because that's what was
written in the previous examples you
must know what they mean what is Delta X
what is it here it's the width of the
cross section so you must decide which
way to your cross sections go and you
can't just choose any cross section
right now in this case the cross
sections are all here right if you read
the other way you get a different shape
entirely okay maybe you could solve it
that way but this is the way it's being
presented to you right so I'm cutting
across and I'm going to get X Delta X
wide cross sections okay good then I
have to add up a whole bunch of things
right I've already decided because I
know I'm cutting this way that my
variable will be X okay a healer in
families would not H we kind of
improvise those because there was their
coordinate system here but there is a
coordinate system here right so
therefore I need to look at the relevant
X values that define the volume where do
I start
and where do I end the answer is I start
negative 4 and I go for some people been
saying to me you started zero because
look it's it's you know zero high when
you go over there but I'm not about
height here I'm about X values right
that's why it's so crucial to understand
why am i choosing which that is I do
okay negative for to fall okay now I've
already decided then I'm gonna have
Delta X in there right that's the width
of each cross section but now I've got
the hard part
now I need to work out the area of the
cross section okay
so therefore you need to see the cross
section this diagrams alright
but it's clouded by too much information
okay so what does the cross section look
like it's triangle and it's an
equilateral triangle now that's lucky
for you because that means you can work
out its area which is what I'm trying to
do to you you can work it out in two
ways okay now before we work out that
area I need some labeling on here right
now be careful I've seen a lot of people
miss this step up they've gotten the
right answer at the end but they've got
at the wrong way so watch carefully and
put your pens down when I label this
thing some of you have gone the path of
giving it some kind of arbitrary name
for its side lake okay and that was sort
of do you okay right in something like
this it's alright because they haven't
provided one to you but just like they
provided I provided a coordinate system
here right there is also a well-defined
value for the length of all these sides
okay now some people naturally have said
well you know when I look at how this is
lining up across this diagram it's
across the y-axis right it's it's up and
down that way if you like so therefore I
call it Y right because it's that's the
direction it's going in but that
distance is not Y okay it's not Y
because it's a coordinate system so
where is y forget out this triangle
where is Y on this diagram and the
answer is Y means how far you are away
from the origin right it's this distance
that's why right well that's one
particular one here's another one and
another one and so on okay so the cross
section doesn't have a base of wife it
has a base of two wine okay all right
now I can work on this you can either go
Pythagoras you can say in this triangle
here you've got Y and 2y which you can
take the square root will give you this
greater 3y work out its area that way
alternatively because it's equilateral
you've got why am i doing that
five on three okay you've got the size
of the angles so you can use treat to
work this out right and you would get
half a B sine PI on three right and side
Pinetree of course is root three on two
right so either way you get the area of
this triangle to be I think it's a
square root of three Y squared yeah cool
that is what I would put in here it's
what I would put in there if it was the
form that I wanted it to be what's wrong
with that it's in it's in wise and in a
second I'm going to integrate with
respect to X okay
but that's okay how do I fix this I use
the relationship between x and y right
even more convening is the relationship
between x squared + y squared from here
I see that Y squared is equal to 16
minus x squared okay
ha I'm finally there I can actually fill
in this area it's the square root of 3
times y squared which is this okay yes
all the work we've formed the sum of all
the volumes now let's make the integral
do I have any constants I can take out I
can take that square root of 3 oh right
I go from negative 4 to 4 they're the
same boundaries right here's my function
and now I'm actually integrating with
respect to X okay now you can evaluate
that if you like but come on we know
lots of properties of definite integrals
right what'll make this easier for me 16
minus x squared that's an even function
is it not so I can say that should be
double the area from naught to 4 I mean
you don't have to do that but why
wouldn't you it makes the integrals so
easy to do
let's integrate I've got two or three at
the front
what's my arm integrand sorry not
integrand my primitive 16x minus X cubed
on three
from naught to 4 not 2 4 2 root 3 that
looks to me like 64 minus 64 on three
minus zero lower bound okay and I think
this works out to 128 on three which
gives you this